le russe bernines s'empare du maillot
jaune à l'issue d'une première étape de
montagne épique contre chambéry et les
arcs luc leblanc est le héros du jour il
sera en direct avec nous dans ce journal
les vacances débutent sous la pluie et
le froid l'inquiétude à la sncf après
l'incarcération de loïk le floch prigent
et les témoignages accablants pour
mladic et karadzic au tribunal
international de la haye madame monsieur
bonsoir le tour de france a connu l'une
de ces étapes les plus folles entre
chambéry et les arcs un cocktail
détonnant de pluie de vente de nuages et
de cols à franchir
au fil des kilomètres on assister au
décrochage de jalabert à l'abandon du
maillot jaune à des chutes
spectaculaires et à la défaillance digne
du rennes ce soir le russe berline et
maillot jaune après cette étape
remportée de quelle façon par luc
leblanc récit d'une journée un peu folle
clairement on l'imaginé en jaune mais il
a vécu une journée noire laurent
jalabert lâché dès les premiers
kilomètres de cette première étape de
montagne dans l'ascension du col de la
madeleine
laurent jalabert qui malgré l'aide de
ses coéquipiers ne parviendra jamais à
rejoindre le peloton et dans ce peloton
bien sûr il y a une durée d'où le holà
nos berlines et roaming heures bref tous
les favoris qui maintiennent une cadence
d'enfer
il y a bien sûr aussi des tentatives
d'échappées comme celle des starting
virenque et le blanc dans la montée du
cormet de roseland mais les deux
français n'arrivent pas à s'entendre
un jour comme celui là la solidarité
nationale ne joue pas la bagarre
heureusement sera de courte durée car il
faut rester concentré la route est
dangereuse et dans la descente vers
bourg-saint-maurice
johan bruyneel bascule dans le ravin une
chute heureusement sans gravité dans la
montée vers les arcs luc leblanc
effectué une extraordinaire remontée
l'ancien champion du monde s'impose avec
plus de 50 secondes d'avancé sur le
peloton
un peloton qui a distancé miguel
indurain le quintuple vainqueur du tour
de france est à son tour victime d'une
incroyable défaillance il coupera la
ligne avec plus de quatre minutes de
retard rétrogradant à la 14e place du
classement général
quant à laurent jalabert arrivée 13
minutes après lui claude blanc il sait
qu'il a perdu toute chance de remporter
le tour de force